pour venir en aide aux agriculteurs
l'organisme au coeur des familles
agricoles s'est inspiré des travailleurs
de rue qui interviennent auprès des
jeunes et des adultes en difficulté en
ville pour créer des postes de
travailleurs de rang qui eux parcourent
la campagne
[Musique]
j'avais bien là que j'ai vu depuis
maintenant deux tours aux mots de savon
moyenne j'ai vu à temps plein qui aident
j'aime rendre directement à la ferme
c'est pas très loin puis vous comme on
dit à monsieur est au courant que vous
deviez nous appeler d'autres
cela fait maintenant trois ans que nenci
langevin parcours les rangs de la région
de chaudière appalaches son emploi
travailleuses de rang son rôle venir en
aide aux producteurs agricoles en
détresse
c'est un producteur laitier
mi-quarantaine monsieur avec sa
conjointe appris une mauvaise nouvelle
il ya peu près six mois madame ans alain
cancer comme qu'elle travaille à temps
plein sur la ferme
ça l'a entraîné que madame le beaucoup
diminuer le travail à la ferme puis mais
monsieur se retrouve tout seul avec
l'entreprise le vétérinaire m'a appris
ce matin parce que il ya y est allé le
rencontrer ça fait deux fois qu'il voit
pour son troupeau puis monsieur pleure
pendant la médecine préventive
puisqu'ils se rajoute ce matin même
ainsi que monsieur a perdu deux bonnes
vaches ya ce qu'on craint le plus chez
un producteur ben c'est qu'ils en
viennent à au suicide
je veux qu'ils me rassure
[Musique]
intervenir dans les moments de crise et
de détresse si le quotidien donne ainsi
l'ange way son premier contact avec
l'agriculteur est déterminant
la première rencontre est primordial
beaucoup il ya 50% de la situation qui
viennent s'alléger juste à un emploi
n'en parlait librement sans avoir la
crainte d'être jugé qu'en sachant très
bien qu'ils sont écoutés
elle doit établir un lien de confiance
surtout les amener à parler c'est
important pour moi que les producteurs
gardent confiance en moi tactics paulo
pour en prévention je suis le plus parce
que oui on dit j'ai eu un appel vous
êtes vous avez mentionné avoir des idées
suicidaires
est-ce que je dois mes en inquiéter
c'est comme ça que j'arrive à entre en
contact avec eux
même si l'ange leur parle de bien-être
nom de détresse elle pose des questions
beaucoup de questions pour les amener à
prendre du recul à évaluer toutes les
possibilités qui s'offrent à eux et à
trouver des solutions pour alléger leur
fardeau les producteurs qui se tourne
vers nancy sont souvent en état de crise
grâce à des passes mais mais mais mais
compétent son coup je me sens un peu en
déséquilibre
je vais je vais appeler les autres
professionnels autour de moi au cours
des ans cette travailleuse de rang a
développé tout un réseau pour l'appuyer
dans son travail
on est souvent chez des producteurs dont
convient avec une relation qui mi-chemin
entre professionnels du personnel la
première selon frédéric tremblay ariane
bornet sont tous du vétérinaire mais
aussi des sentinelles formé par nancy
langevin
des fois on a vu les enfants grandir
c'est les enfants maintenant qu'ils ont
la ferme donc on a une relation quand
même assez forte avec la famille quand
nous on voit qu'un producteur négliger
sa business souvent sa dernière chose
qu'on néglige souvent ils vont virer
coins ronds à 20 des places mais pas
d'un état
enfin quand nous avec notre nos yeux de
tes nerfs on voit quelqu'un ce programme
de bain et probablement quelque chose
dans le monde c'est déjà un signal
d'alarmé langer avec le fait que le
producteur peut pleurer
peut être un petit peu perdues au niveau
du thym
avant la difficulté à effectuer ces
tâches des choses comme ça
parfois le producteur a besoin de temps
d'arrêt loin de sa ferme un moment de
réflexion pour y voir plus clair
ce retrait préventif se fait ici à la
maison de répit à saint-hyacinthe en eau
tvg une résidence en pleine ville pour
sortir l'agriculteur de son milieu pour
qu'ils ne voient ni chaud ni animaux ni
tracteur dépaysement rue beauregard
dirige l'organisme au coeur des familles
agricoles qui coordonne les activités
des travailleurs de rang et la maison de
répit
ceux qui viennent ici ce sont souvent
des cas plus sérieux
ici les producteurs sont suivies jour et
nuit
les rencontres sont plus soutenues la
travailleuse sociale quitte si qui rend
compte la personne et la personne n'est
jamais laisser seul il ya toujours
quelqu'un de l'équipe qui est avec elle
pendant la journée et aussi avec un
autre le soir la nuit quelqu'un qui
démarre à la maison ici pour les
accompagner
lorsque le producteur qui était prêt
quelques jours de thérapie intensive
il en sort transformé on y voit là ils
rentrent ils ont les épaules et ont les
épaules et creuser on surveille regarda
taille son papa a regardé à nous
regarder mais sans compte rapidement que
ce qui le faisait à porter on les voit
le tranquillement à relever leur laver
car puis de remettre un sourire dans les
usages pas que c'est vraiment l'occasion
pour le donner la chance de se reprendre
à main haut qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui
c'est quoi c'est quoi joue enfin pour
mes enfants
au début sa création en 2013 la maison
de répit pouvait accueillir jusqu'à 75
personnes par année en 2019
il y en a eu qu'une vingtaine le fait
qu'il y ait de plus en plus de
travailleurs de rang dans les régions
n'est pas étranger à cette situation
aujourd'hui ils sont une dizaine à
parcourir les campagnes on sent conques
lorsqu'on m'a quelqu'un a placé un
certain temps d'adaptation mais un
coutelas personnes aient connu puis est
reconnu par le milieu
les demandes d'intervention augmente
avec les années
en 2010 7157 interventions sont
enregistrés 2010 8657 2010 neuf autres
banques 2066 interventions et cela
n'inclut pas les interventions des trois
travailleurs de rang qui ne sont pas
sous l'égide de l'organisme au coeur des
familles agricoles
[Musique]
nancy longerait et la première
travailleuses de rang embauché au québec
au début elle a dû se faire connaître
elle allait de ferme en ferme au hasard
pour rencontrer des producteurs
agricoles aujourd'hui les producteurs la
connaissent
le tout d'abord monsieur tu es content
d'un mois ce matin c'est en attarde à
pau et y était très content j'ai pris
une rencontre avec fruits au début de la
semaine prochaine pour venir le voir à
nouveau pour discuter avec lui mettront
place des travailleurs de rang c'est la
priorité de l'organisme au coeur des
familles agricoles
c'est aux citoyens complémentarité avec
les centres de prévention juste pour
apporter les meilleurs soutiens la can
le plus grande collaboration et de
travailler aussi avec les réseaux de la
santé
dernièrement québec a annoncé une aide
de 300 mille dollars pour augmenter les
ressources sur le terrain mais cette
aide n'est pas permanente
l'avenir de ces services dead est donc
loin d'être assurée
[Musique]
ailleurs au canada le soutien offert aux
agriculteurs en situation de détresse
varie beaucoup
certaines provinces offrent des services
d' écoutes téléphoniques mais dans bien
des endroits où pays
aucun service spécifique n'est prévu
pour les producteurs agricoles